Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome. This is Active
Inference Livestream number 35.1. It's
January 24, 2023.
Today we're here with Jordan Hall and
Matthew Prakowski. We're going to have a
very interesting discussion. So thank
you both for joining. We will begin with
a hello and introduction from Jordan.
Matthew will then set some context that
will launch us into a dialogue that will
take us on through. So thanks again.
And Jordan, please.
Jordan Hall: Turns out I lied in the preamble, so a little
bit of introduction. I'm noticing and
this is, I think, part of the real
interest of having a conversation with
Matthew is something like it would
be nice, I think, and implausible for us
to actually produce something new and
useful in this 90 minutes time span.
And I expect that we'll want to be using
something like a transparentigmatic
method. So we should be grabbing
concepts from a variety of different
disciplines and frames and applying them
in the area of inquiry and endeavoring
to use that to actually identify
something that is specific and perhaps
hasn't been as articulated or deeply
investigated, at least to my awareness,
of course, before. And so the end
result, hopefully will actually be worth
actually having been done and to have
been participated in.
Definitely. I hope that at least this
recording, in and of itself as an
artifact, will be something useful for a
number of people who might have been
paying attention to the initial context
and that we can bring together as we
typically do the many types of frames
that we've been exploring in between our
conversations that are quite hurtful
and oftentimes bear fruit in
conversation. So I always look forward
to our conversation specifically for
that reason why we
are here this morning. Or I guess what
did catalyze this initially was a tweet
that I kind of randomly sent out the
other day as I had a network of concepts
floating around in my head around
emergence, governance, the tendencies
toward which that pattern flows.
And so the tweet may be best to just
read it because
that all forms of governance trend
toward parasitic corruption should be
the first quote unquote law of
political, quote unquote science. The
only questions are how long before this
becomes unsustainable? Does it also
generate valuable byproducts and will it
fail catastrophically or adaptively?
And so just a general frame for the
conversation is to go on the lines of as
we move through the world together and
attempt to identify points of tension in
terms of the relationship between our
communities and the embedding context in
which they exist and attempt to navigate
the world such that they can retain
their ability to function, to cohere,
to generate new solutions that
help them mediate the tensions in the
world that are constantly attempting to
or constantly acting as a force against
those structures as we come together to
try to network
ourselves such that we can function
adaptive to create systems for doing so.
And that's evolved quite a bit over time
from informal systems at the tribal
level, at smaller social scales with
respect to structures that had much
greater coherence. Just as a function of
the fact that everyone knew each other,
everyone was around one another in a
daily context, had a deep history in
terms of their relational contextual
knowledge of those interpersonal
relations, these lineages. And so you
didn't need a great deal of abstraction
in the quote unquote political domain.
You didn't need to conceptualize an
abstract structure and then attempt to
convince people that this was the
legitimate structure to buy into as a
stewardship mechanism for themselves.
But as we scaled up, we started to
introduce these sorts least action. And
we are certainly in a time now where
it's worth asking this question as we
create abstractions that are into which
we pour our political energies. For
example, the idea of a democratic
governance or the sort of republic that
we live in in the United States.
To what extent is there a tendency of
those who are given stewardship over
that, given their placement, given their
necessity, necessary placement within
this mechanism, but also in the
necessity of the mechanism, but also
just the structure of that mechanism
being responsible as a small subset of
the population for stewarding this large
abstraction and this large degree of
attention and this large degree of
responsibility, is it possible for that
to be resistant to corruption across
long periods of time? Is it inevitable
that that corruption will exist? And
this was the claim in the Tweet that
people will fundamentally begin to make
choices that direct all of that
attention, energy toward their own ends,
as opposed to the ends, ostensible ends
of the collective. And then if that is a
given, what frames
can we hold? Despite the fact that this
is a given, that can still act as
evaluative criteria and so a useful
evaluated criteria? Which is what sort
of those three. Ideas that I provided
related to in terms of the degree to
which that can be an unsustainable or
sustainable structure, to the extent
that it still generates valuable
byproducts, even though that corruption
is necessary or inherently emergent
within. It or whether it will fail
catastrophically or adaptively?
Will it undermine itself entirely or
will it actually, within itself,
despite that corruption, be able to
surface new patterns into which itself
can fail as a kind of lifeboat that
increasingly expands its own capacity?
So I'll kind of step away now and just
give time for reflection and analysis on
yelp's part. But that was just sort of
the initial frame that I think catalyzed
some conversation here. All right,
well, there's a whole bunch of different
things that are, I think, implicated.
And I noticed that put
a variety of different plates on the
table without having to understand
exactly what meal we're eating just yet,
in no particular order. One thing that
comma up is I feel like there's an
invocation of a frame that I've used a
lot, and that is something along the
lines of, like, major eras or apocs in
the arc of evolution, specifically in
the context of humans. And so the first
era, which I refer to
often as unconscious evolution or
ordinary evolution is the period that I
think you were referring to be something
like lineage, where there's the binding
constraints, the various kinds of
characteristics. Of behavior that steer
the collective choice making of a group
of indigenous humans
was largely a consequence of a very long
time and iterations under the ordinary
constraints of what I'll just call
ordinary biological evolution. So lots
of trial and error and conservation of
relatively fit behavior, very tightly
knit and with all the various advantages
that are associated with that modality
of exploring possibility space. The
second era, the second APOC, would be
conscious design. And I think this is
the domain where we see most of the
problematics. And I'll invoke people
like Tainter, Ari, Kahn as other
individuals who have pointed to the
problematics that seem to be intrinsic
to the APOC or the modality of conscious
design. And of course, one of the sort
of most fundamental challenges is that
it exits us from the equilibrium
or the homeostatic feedback loops that
are characteristic of unconscious
evolution. So humans are able to operate
in the mode of conscious design. We
begin to create novelty in the
environment that produces asymmetry in
relationship with all the other feedback
loops that we happen to have been
embedded in contextually, but we don't
actually fully understand the
consequences of the asymmetries that
we're producing. And this creates a
whole series of cascade effects. So
Tainter explores that in the context of
how a designed social infrastructure
produces an arc that has a built in
enclosure. Because as we sort of play
out the entropy that was built into the
inception of that social infrastructure,
which may take generations or even many
generative, we find ourselves collapsing
back into the complex domain of the
unconscious evolutionary basis. And then
we have a reset. I think Kun more or
less explores the same basic dynamic
within the particular domain of science.
And I think they're largely, if you look
at them as being examples of a more
generalized problematic or even dynamic,
you can then use that to create a meta
theory.
Similarly, I'm not sure exactly who
studied this most carefully. Perhaps
Hayek looking at it in the context of
businesses, which have a very similar
and very well studied dynamic. The S
curve of a business structure where an
entrepreneurial group,
usually one or two or five founders like
a very small group operating in many
ways principally from the unconscious
evolutionary stage like operating in
very much a human. Indigenous modality
using a lot of the basic human dynamics
to be in deep relationship with each
other and form a very fluid, open,
coherent governance. Highly generative
produces a large gradient or a large
well of potential. But then as it
structures itself into the conscious
design mode and starts creating an
organizational structure, it plays the
various tools and in many ways, kind of
replicates the arc of social structures
in general, recreating the rise and fall
of civilizations and then forms some
form of closure and that eventually
dies. I think been studied pretty
thoroughly in a number of different
locations.
And given that language and I haven't
actually brought in parasite, which is a
very good so it's just bring in parasite
and the notion of niche. So a general
principle of evolution is that every
niche will be ultimately explored. And
there's something about both the
presence of entropy in designed
constructs or actually any kind of
gradient, any kind of gradient has a
dynamic of entropy, but it also has the
dynamic of once a gradient is produced,
that gradient represents a niche. And
the exploration and exploitation of that
niche, of which parasitism is one
fundamental strategy, seems to be
something that needs to be we need to be
aware of and think about how that's
addressed across different apocs.
And then the last piece I would throw
out is something like, okay,
if we're endeavoring to move, Hinton a
third mode, which would be something
like the APOC of conscious evolutionary
approach, which is able to sort of
combine the best of the both and perhaps
avoid the negatives of both, by the way,
entirely by hypothesis. I have no
compelling reason to believe this is
actually plausible.
One of the things that might be
interesting is to look at the phenotype
genotype dynamics, ie.
Evolution seems to have woven at a very
deep level what I'll call a Coda, a very
profound modal shift, which is that all
phenotypes die, but there's continuity
in the fact that the phenotype produces
an embodied version of the genotype. So
the genotype has continuity exclusively,
however, mediated by the phenotype and
the phenotype has a kind of continuum,
but exclusively mediated by the
genotype. And the two are very,
very distinct in terms of their physical
characteristics. Right. The things that
are associated with energetic gradients
are qualitatively distinct and the
shifting back and forth between the two
seems to be a solution to the kind of
problem that we're actually talking
about. Okay, so that's what I'm putting
into the mix, into the stew.
Number of ingredients to work with.
Yes. So beginning at
the beginning of your statement with
respect to the introduction of Conor,
hike and tainter,
this is going to be some grammatic work.
I think we have to do as well here.
Because you use the word closure a
couple of times and the manner in which
you used it was sort of the
epoch ending book end context in a way.
Is that a fair characterization of how
you felt you were using it in a way that
sort of the closing of an
era, the end of an era the end of a
phase, I. Think even more pointedly to
the notion of a thermodynamically
closed system. Okay,
these kinds of systems, the proposition
I'm making is that they are closed
systems and so therefore they have a
finite time until they active.
Something like an entropic equilibrium.
And that arc of the
playing out of that time is the story of
their particular escrow, I would
propose. Okay, interesting.
Yeah, there's a fascinating
tension along the lines of sort of
stable or unstable equilibriums or if
you want to layer in another. I'm not
sure how familiar you are with the work
of Terrence Deacon, but he's quite
interesting insofar as he provides
thermodynamic frameworks around the
ideas of different emergent behaviors
that flow from sort of this first
homeostatic level which is systems that
tend to essentially equilibrium. So he
introduced a little bit of language
called orthograde as a sort of abstract,
general term of like a number of systems
that tend toward a more homogeneous
state, let's say, or a more stable
state, and then contragrade. Which is
essentially the capacity of any system
to give it an ambient orthograde context
to sort of act against that in some way
continuously or with some degree of
stability. And he builds a framework of
actually showing that certain types of
structure itself. And this kind of
resonates with a lot of Kaufman's work
in terms of the origins of order,
looking for non evolutionary, just
physical constraints that give rise in
processes that interact with those
physical constraints that themselves
give rise to certain forms of order in
the world. So Deacon's claim is
something along the lines of two types
of systems that might themselves tend
toward stable dissipative structure
if put in relationship in a particular
way with one another, can then give rise
to that sort of frustration boundary
flow through that frustration boundary
give rise to some sort of actual
structure in the world or pattern in the
world. And the archetype of example he
uses there is something called like a
Rayleigh Benard cell which is heat
trying to energy trying to flow through
water or oil with a particular
viscosity. And the first thing you get
is the Attial bubbling of the heat
rising. But at a particular point the
energy can't escape efficiently enough
so it actually takes on this structure
hexagonal lattice. So you get these
little cells, right? And if you've ever
been to Pacific Northwest or other areas
with like basalt rock with these
hexagonal columns, you can actually see
this exact thing embodied when lava
cools and then cools and tries to cool
release that energy in the same way and
forms these giant hexagonal rock
structures. In any case, my whole point
of introducing that line of thought is
that I think that there are with respect
to homeostatic systems,
this idea of closure is an interesting
one because people are researchers such
as like Monteville. Marco Kaufman as
well, with his work Cycles and
Monteville omasio. They have this idea
of constraint closures, which is why I
went in this direction, which is deeply
tied into the function of in their idea
of their concept. They use the concept
of a constraint as sort of a symmetry
across time. And so that symmetry across
time, think of something like an enzyme,
right? The enzyme has its own structure
that is maintained across time, but in
its interaction with some other process,
it sort of locally breaks that symmetry
to produce a transformation. And it sort
of acts as a sort of you COVID look at
it as like a functional or dynamical
boundary that also changes what bounces
off of it. And then if you order these
boundaries in a particular way and
close that loop, which is where you get
this closure, which is in many ways the
way that I tend to use the word closure
these days, the reason I'm laying the
groundwork is just because this idea of
closure is very fundamental. The kind of
ways I've been thinking about this
particular topic of emergence and
governance, once that becomes
closed, then you can start talking about
these patterns of autocatalysis,
whether that's a self reinforcing loop
and what it actually self reinforces.
And to the extent that we're talking
about governance, I think it's relevant
because of the fact that at each one of
those points there are aspects, there
are side affect of that function that
are the inputs of one of these other
functions. But then there are also side
effects that can have other functions
in the context in which this closure
might exist. And I think when we're
talking about governance and the
lifecycle of governance, we might be
talking about something like that
initial closure coming into being
functionally such that its overall net
byproducts might be adaptive. But to the
extent we become reflexive in
understanding and this is that conscious
evolution is conscious management to the
extent that we can identify the closure
and Clark mapping it and actually
analyzing the points and the flows
within our own minds as individuals we
can start playing games with it. To the
extent that that closure and its side
effects shift to a point where it
actually shunts perhaps some of that
energy that should be going to the
adaptive capacity of the overall closure
into sort of sub games of people's
individual political dynamics, personal
lives, wealth building endeavors that
are within their own frame of reference
but not represented in that closure that
they are now able to see and take
advantage of. Which you might also
introduce later in things like the
action effect, where it's like if you're
close to the money spigot and you see
the game that's being played, you are
more capable of taking literally that
energy that's being released into the
market and directing it into places that
might be more to your own interest.
Even if you are saying and claiming that
they're in the general interest of that
broader collective closure that we've
created supposedly in the economic sense
by the Fed to maintain homeostatic or
homeodynamic stability at this financial
level. So when you kind of bring in
those concepts, they're very resonant
with the way I've been thinking about
it. But I just wanted to sort of
establish that context for grammar with
respect to closure, because I think it's
quite critical to the way I've also been
thinking about these tendencies. Yeah,
that was great. Thank you.
With regard to that last point, when
we're looking at the particular
phenomenon or human endeavor of
governance, we have a special case. I
think this is very interesting to be
able to focus. So the general case we
could talk about in the context of folks
like Tainter and Coon and Hayek,
which is just things that happen in
human built kinds of organizational
systems that have these various dynamics
built in governance is particularly
because it's of that sort. However, the
whole point of governance, it is in fact
designed to be the thing that address
the problematic you were just
discussing. Right? And so the whole
point is actually the recursion or the
microcosmic boundary where governance is
itself subject to its own,
we'll call right now, I guess we'll use
closure. I'm not quite sure if I'm even
using it right, because that was a lot
you just put in there. But sort of the
failure conditions that we're talking
about. And of course, you can then
imagine this kind of an infinite regress
of, okay, we'll do the governance on
governance, and then the governance on
the governance on governance. Is there
reason to believe that there's actually
a way to find a loop back whereby that
whole meta system actually has something
like a higher level of stability?
And you raise a lot of different points
in the very beginning in terms of the
three previous questions of what the
word stability might even mean. It might
not mean that it lasts forever, in fact,
it rarely wouldn't, but it might mean
that it failed. Really interestingly.
So that like the biological organism, I
die. I don't live forever, but my life
might be part of a larger arc that has a
completely different continuity process.
And that's actually the thing that we're
thinking about. So I might die.
Interestingly. And so that's a very
different solution to the basic problem.
Right. What else was in
there? There was something really
interesting where I kind of tried to put
okay, so I noticed also that
I'll call it geometry. So almost like
the third mode. So you discussed
a characteristic anticipative systems
where relationships between two
different structured possibility spaces
produces a new architecture.
It actually produces order at a purely
physical level. And I would say this is
something like there's principle of
least action, principles of nature that
are as fundamental as thermodynamics and
because they're as fundamental, they
constrain the playing out of
thermodynamics.
And. It'S important to recognize we
actually have that, that's in the
toolkit, we can use this. And one of the
things I was thinking about is that one
of the things that oftentimes shows
failure conditions in human design
systems is vertical or horizontal
asymmetry. So, for example,
if I have one person endeavoring to
govern, those issues are actually in
business. That should be the ordinary
sort of business organization. The
notion of span of control in military
and for all bureaucracies is pretty well
understood. But if I have a manager or a
business governance function, they
generally can't actually govern more
than a small number of other people. So
if I have a single manager, one
governance function, and they're
endeavoring to govern, say, 500,000
people, that asymmetry in terms of
information, like, I think in terms of
information theory, perception, sense
making and effective choice making that
can be actuated down, will create a wide
variety of gaps and niches for
parasitism. But maybe there's something
to be found in the context of a proper
geometry where the information asymmetry
is inside of some sort of conscious
boundary. We can even think about in
terms of what's actually possible in
terms of the space of consciousness,
how we can produce larger spaces of
consciousness, and then how we can
actually design information flows that
are within that space. So that energy
flow is actually held within a
governance envelope that doesn't produce
these niches for parasitism.
Yeah, I mean, 100%. That's very
resonant. I think that in
that context, to pick apart this
symmetry asymmetry question a bit more,
this relates to this sort of a
long line of undercurrent of
political science that's not as popular,
that sort of flows through machiavelli.
Moscow. Burnham that vein of just
pointing out the side effects
of this kind of asymmetry with respect
to the idea of leadership, or sort of
the raification of any system in so
far as it must take place within a
subset of the population. It can't be
even the idea of democratic governance
itself has to be acted out on the day to
day by a fraction of the entire group
on behalf of which is being played out
in theory. And so that subset of people
who are identified then
become responsible for enacting that
game with a particular degree of
integrity. And I think that that concept
of integrity, this kind of relates to
maybe the quality of those governance
envelopes you're talking about in the
structure, but also the scope and scale
over which perhaps responsibility is one
way of thinking about it but then also
accountability because I think to some
extent that accountability,
transparency, game to the extent more
and more people are playing out their
lives while trusting you to do the right
thing. Especially part of that is going
to mean that more of their resources are
pulling into you with that trust, which
increases the incentives for you to
potentially do something that they will
not see while their eyes are directed
elsewhere. It's kind of like I like to
use the game of the more money that's in
the pot on the table, right? The more
you have to be careful going to the
bathroom. If everyone leaves the room
and you just leave one guy in there,
you got to be a little bit careful,
because even if that's a very
trustworthy person at that table,
the larger that pod gets, you start
beginning to test that degree of
integrity. And that's kind of that same
asymmetry is like, the better system of
governing. The best systems of
coherence, they create the more of the
systems we create to generate value. If
they are actually successful, it is
exactly that value that's created by
them that becomes the temptation for
defection. And so this is very
interesting with respect to this
envelope question because it transforms
into this accountability and
representation question, I think. And to
the extent that we are forced to
represent these systems or to have
accountability with these systems, I
think we live in a very interesting time
because we are beginning to be able to
have representative granularity and
transparency in ways that were never
before possible and using those
to sort of act as proxies for
maintaining integrity and binding
constraints on people's behavior. And
it's an interesting balance because we
obviously if someone is a representative
we want those people to enact the
highest ideal in theory of their
representative position. That being
said, we also need to have that position
be somewhat attractive. And to the
extent that anyone is looking to act
out that position if it is fully
constrained and surveilled they might no
longer be interested in taking on that
position. One solution to that might be
something along the lines of like we'll
automate the whole thing but humans
don't as embodied beings, humans don't
tend to respond well to the idea of an
abstract entity that they don't really
fully understand the internals and that
kind of aren't actually hitting our
mirror neurons in the right way either.
We're not getting that reflexive
property of like yes, I intuitively
understand this thing. I think we get
also innately suspicious whenever the
idea of some sort of abstract system
acting as our representative or acting
as our governance. Even if that were
Bull transparent and less likely to
defect against us or probably would not
defect against us, we might just rebel
against it anyway. So there's sort of
this possible Catch 22 there. Those are
some thoughts there. Yeah, that's
interesting. That last
piece let me see this,
right? The last piece, which was just
called the AI governance Piece is
kind of worthy. It's tremendously worthy
of a really serious deep dive and maybe
sooner rather than later. We're actually
accelerating in the direction where that
kind of science fiction narrative is
plausibly and let's not say like we
don't know these things happen in step
functions they don't tend to go on a
straight curve, but plausibly is on the
event horizon, so we may actually have
to wrestle with that. I would propose,
though I cannot prove it with adequate
rigor, so it would require a
collaborative effort. But I propose that
in fact, that idea can't work.
And there's actually, I believe, and
actual rigorous proof that is available
that the notion of a fully automated
governance system is intrinsically
unstable. But that doesn't mean that we
won't try to do it and trap ourselves
thereby. So let me back up a
little bit before we get there because
we can talk about the stuff that's sort
of in between. And this is very
much the Tainter story, more or less,
we get the idea of the
first movement is the relationship
between contextualization and
decontextualization, which may be the
thing that humans specifically most
fundamentally do, is the ability to
decontextualize. We can pull the salient
elements of some particular landscape
out as we see fit, right? Not just by
virtue of evolutionary fitness. We can
actually fluidly identify
characteristics that we'd like to pop
into the foreground and sort of reify
down into principles and then most
specifically endeavor to govern, to
optimize for or against or modulate
according to our own preferences. And of
course, one of the things that we can do
with that power of decontextualization
is we can then brain architectures on
the basis of that decontextualization,
which is the term technology. That's
what that means, right? Technology is
the ability to use decontextualization
to design in nature phenomena
that are specifically optimizing for
particular principles that we've been
able to pull out of what is otherwise a
larger million. And I
would propose that this is at the basis
of both the strength and the weakness of
the design, like the epoch of design.
And the limitations of
decontextualization are very deeply
woven into the fragility or the
problematic of, say, Taintroid style
curves, all the things that we're
talking about. So of course, in the
process of decontextualization, on the
one hand we're able to identify what's
called the most the most relevant or the
most salient characteristics of some
system and then we can begin to control
for them, say, okay, I want more
calories per unit yield of wheat.
But of course, the the inverse is also
true. By virtue of decontextualization,
we move away from an ability to have
high quality perception of all of the
other things that are going on in that
embedded system. So we lose track of
them and by virtue of losing track of
them to the degree to which they matter.
And of course, now we're getting into
kind of like something around heisenberg
and deep chaos there, meaning tiny,
tiny differences, microcosmic
differences, possibly at the Planck
limit, tend to build up into large
consequences. So that as we
decontextualize, we render into the
invisible. We render out of the realm of
design, out of the. Realm of the
conscious, a whole bunch of things that
were in fact, by definition calculated
via relevance, realization at the
unconscious evolutionary level just by
sheer actual having causal effect on the
system. And then of course, we're
setting ourselves up. We're setting
ourselves up to have unintended
consequences, cascade out into our
larger environment. And then what we
tend to do then and this is the Taintrid
move and the thing that I want to kind
of bring into the foreground is that we
tend to double down. So what we do is we
will bricolage or we will collude new
technologies at the edge. Oh, okay,
this particular problem is showing up
great. I'm going to do the same move.
I'm going to look at that problem.
Foreground or decontextualize the
elements that I can identify in the
problem, put together a new technology,
connect it to the previous technology.
We kind of get one of these. Remember
building mobiles when you were a kid and
kind of add something at the balance
point. It can come layers, layers down.
And of course the point that somebody
like Tainter very specifically makes and
I think Conor also maybe not quite as
clearly makes is that we then get lost
in our own creation. The machine that we
have built has so much complicatedness
to it. It has so many different things
going on that we're no longer actually
able to be mastered of our own machine.
And this moves us back into an
unconscious design phase. So now we're
effectively maintaining something that
we don't understand in many cases our
generations past its origin story. So we
have a tiny window of awareness in a
much larger field. But that larger field
doesn't have the advantage of a tightly
coupled, deeply nuanced, complex, fully
contextualized characteristic. Instead,
it actually has lots of these little
decontextualization gaps, foregrounds
and backgrounds, but we're super not
aware of them. We've lost track of it a
lot. And now this is part of the niche
environment. Every one of those gaps
becomes a niche for various forms of
parasitism or become places where local
entropy is collected and ant be
addressed because they're effectively in
various kinds of blind spots or in what
the Santa Fe people would call frozen
accidents of our own complicated
machinery. I. E. It's just a gap that
arose because of the way that we built
the control system. And for us to
actually this address the gap, we have
to deconstruct the control system. But
the game theory doesn't work. The cost
of deconstructing the control system is
something that we're not willing to do.
So the local entropy just gathers and
gathers and gathers until it festers and
it eventually creates a breakage that we
sort of unconsciously just accepted is
what's going to happen.
Okay, I think that sort of played out
what I had there. I can hear you, by the
way. I'm just going to get some more
water. Okay? Yeah. No problem. No
problem. Yeah. And so,
I mean, that obviously ties into the
dynamic of sort of at the more
colloquial level, the fact that humans
don't act, in general, creatures,
biological organisms, but especially
humans that are, in theory, through one
lens, known. To be the kind of creature
that attempts to look into the future,
the horizon of possibility, and attempt
to act in line with a manner in which
that feature remains habitable. Let's
say. But then there's always this long
term, short term tension with respect to
at what point do the possible threats
do the potential threats start to
realize themselves or actualize
themselves at levels that generate
sufficient sufficient you COVID call.
Entropy or suffering or something that
sort of shakes you strongly enough or
deeply enough to change behavior or your
frame of reference at the appropriate
scale to produce transformation that can
respond to whatever that blind spot that
you're mentioning by the process of
decontextualization whatever has been
manifesting in that blind spot that is
then threatening the integrity of the
process or the capacity of that process
to maintain its continuity across time.
One thing that really struck me that's
interesting as well, and I think I guess
I've been playing around with a lot of
these types of ideas lately in terms of
with respect to words and the sort of
inversion capacities or cyclic
capacities of taking a concept and
flipping it and seeing what happens.
This idea of decontextualization is
fascinating to me because when you're
discussing it in my mind, something
that's popping up is another way of
looking at this very phenomenologically
is that if we look at ourselves as
categorizing beings attention.
To. And to me, what categorizing beings
tends to mean is having a functional
attractor of some sort that we're
binding representations to with this
sort of agglomerative tendency of more
and more things that have that likeness
or sameness or are associated with that
network building over time. One of
the essential characteristics is that we
can't focus on everything at a given
point in time and therefore we have to
live inside a given framework that
mediates, facilitates and hones our
attention capacity to actually navigate
that process of using this category
structure to relate to actualities and
possibilities continuously across time.
And so, interestingly enough,
the concept of that ambience. One way of
looking at decontextualization might
also be a process of hyper
contextualization in the sense where we
are taking a very small representative
subspace, we're identifying a particular
set of concepts. I think abstraction is
a way of looking at this right. Like you
were saying, there's a set of
similarities here and they're graspable
enough within my mind at the moment. So
I'm going to take those and then begin
to act as if I'm living inside those as
the full context. And so through that
zooming in to the abstraction or to that
subset of the possible pattern space, I
begin to act as if that subset is the
entire ambience and therefore become
blind to everything that is not inside
that subspace. And so you're sort of
living inside the micro niche, this
micro gradient, because you identified a
useful gradient inside that abstraction
for some perhaps instrumental or even
something that was truly convincing.
The idea of calculus is extremely
compelling and we got a great deal of
adaptive utility out of that concept.
But does it hit a limit at some level in
terms of the metaphors and the way of
seeing the world through the lens of
calculus? Does it start to break down?
I mean, I would argue yes. I think there
are boundaries when you start to see the
world as a set of instance. With respect
to my studies in consciousness and like
the emergence of consciousness and
topology of consciousness. I think one
of the things that actually has done
inhibits us quite a bit is trying to
think of it as an instantaneous property
of a system, something that could in
theory be pointed out as a point on a
tangent curve somewhere. Right? So in
any case, like this decontextualization
frame, I think is a very deep frame.
Andy Clark of this phenomenological
tendency. We have to see patterns and
then start living within side those
patterns as an adaptive framework and
then just to close us off, I guess,
with respect to the Julian take on that
as well, he's well known for structure
of scientific evolution. But my favorite
essay, essay by Kun is an essay called
The Essential Tension, which is like the
essay in which he kind of responds to
the public response to his structure of
scientific revolution. Speaking in front
of, I think it was the APA or something
like that at the time, and saying
essentially I've been largely
misinterpreted by people who want to use
that work as a justification for
throwing off all constraints. But in
reality, what he was saying, this
essential detention was like, there's a
frame that's established a very formal,
rigid frame. And the point of that
formal, rigid frame and discipline is to
move to a point of convergence. Not
because the convergence point is the
transcendental ideal that we absolutely
must get to, but because by acting as
if that convergence process is worth
moving toward, as we converge, we will
realize what is outside of that cone of
convergence, so to speak. It'll start
showing up as aberrations. And then by
collecting those aberrant pieces of
information, we can begin to realize.
Oh, okay. This is how we can print, in a
principled and structured and continuum
manner, once again. Open that frame back
up,
recontextualize the decontextualization,
or, like, zoom back out of that hyper
focus contextualization and
synthesize a new frame that doesn't just
jettison the value of the previous
frame. Arbitrarily but that also isn't
myopically focused beyond a point of
critical collapse, let's say, on
pursuing that singular interpretation of
the old framing. And so I think to some
extent, this is the set of patterns that
we're trying to work with. When we talk
about,
I think, instead of the structure of
scientific revolutions, we're like,
we're beginning to see the traces of the
necessity of that analogous process
occurring at the structural level of
governance. And this is sort of the
zeitgeist of our era, with many people
attempting to place ideas, place new
frame possibilities. How should we
direct our attention into the space of
public discussion and hopefully
experimentation and try to figure out,
can we get some positive signals so that
as this prior frame begins to
disintegrate, are there lifeboats that
are actually capable of carrying more
than one to five people at a time?
Yeah. So it's notable that
Tainter referred to it as the collapse
of complex societies. And I think the
proper way of describing what what Coon
was describing was not so much a
paradigm shift as a paradigm
catastrophe. And I
think there's a very specific point
there. We're we're actually looking for
paradigm shift. You know, it's okay, I
got a paradigm. Okay, now it's time to
shift in that movement. And I would like
to very much invoke here the cognitive
science notions of opponent processing
and how the brain, very specifically,
all the way down to the most basic
animals, uses modal distinctions.
Specifically, the one I was thinking
about is very much the dynamic where,
okay, it's time to focus on a very
localized task, but there's something
happening at a meta level that allows
and requires in fact, they're shifting
back to diffuse and then moving back and
forth, right? And that action of modal
distinction, right brain, left brain
distinction, are qualitatively different
in how they go about orienting towards
where to allocate attention and even how
to do sense making in the relationship
to perception. And then there's a meta
dynamic that moves back and forth
between them. So that kind of a
tricameral structure at a very deep
modal distinction or qualitatively
distinct level seems like it's the
proper design for any kind of new kind
of collective intelligence. And I was
brought to mind of the of the
distinction between thinking and
simulated thinking that I was trying to
make, gosh, about five years ago. And I
think that was that was oftentimes also
not fully grasp. So if you wouldn't
mind, I'll just recapitulate because the
point is very specifically the point we
have two modes, at least definitely two
modes of thinking. One mode that I
called habit mode and one mode that I
called Explore mode. And I'm not
necessarily trying to say that I
invented any of this. And there are many
people I'm sure you've done a much
better job as trying to point out. The
thing I'm trying to point out is not
that, but the idea that habit mode like
paradigm is able to take advantage of a
variety of different frameworks that are
relatively well designed for a
particular domain and therefore quickly
and accurately and predictably be able
to make sense and select appropriate
choices in the context of a certain
domain. That's a very functional thing
to have. Explore mode is a mode that is
modally distinct, has a more diffuse
awareness, much more contextually aware,
is oriented towards things like insight,
I. E. Breaking existing assumptions and
very oriented towards the subtle things
that may not ordinarily be noticed in
habit mode but may actually be relevant.
And that's why we have to have this
different Explore mode. So the meta
processes is okay, which mode should I
be in right now? Am I am in a concept
where Explorer mode is the most adaptive
mode or am I in a context where habit
mode is the most adaptive mode? And can
I fluidly move back and forth so that's
that third. So I've got one, two, three
and the premise of this notion of
simulated thinking is that there's
something about habit mode where we can
get stuck in it. So it somehow habit
mode breaks this third governance layer
that allows us to fluidly move back and
force and then gets us more and more
stuck in habit mode in particular where
we begin to build a habit that simulates
governance. And then we're in trouble
because at that point we can't actually
make proper use of explore mode because
we actually haven't got the capacity.
All we can do is when the governance
system is saying hey, it's time to move
to Explore mode, habit mode says oh,
I've got it. And then produces something
vaguely like Explore mode but still
within the fundamentals of habitat mode.
And you can sort of extend that to all
the different examples we've used,
right? This operates in any dynamics.
So in coon's model it would be anomalies
are being thrown and the largest system
is saying hey, there's something wrong
with our paradigm. But the paradigmatic
mind says well, I'll just produce a more
complex version of my existing paradigm
to absorb those anomalies into it. Or
I'll use the function of ignoring. In
other words, I'll put them into an area
of local entropy and just kind of let
them sit for however long, maybe
forever, ideally, right? And the
metaphors is that's the problem that is
the problem of conscious design is that
getting stuck and not actually having
the opponent processing built robustly
enough that we can move from habit
into Explore without having to go
through a crisis. The problem is not
that sometimes our habits aren't
functional, we have to move to a
different mode. The problem is sometimes
we get addicted to our habits and the
only way we can get out of them is
actually to go through hitting rock
bottom. And that's a very adaptive way
of solving that kind of problem.
Just sort of like to test the language a
bit and make sure that I'm with you here
and also use it potentially to
synthesize some of the topics that we've
been talking about. It's fascinating
to consider this in light of this
question in terms of parasitism that
we've been talking about and also the
question of the benefits of parasitism,
possibly right, because you're talking
about this catastrophic or this
catastrophe, which is in dynamics
systems in many ways analogous to
falling off a cliff in the map that is
actually exactly like that in many ways.
And so it
could be the case, right. That one way
of looking at parasitism. If you can
endogenize it or if you can actually
internalize some amount of it or look at
it as a property of systems is
potentially the smoothing function for
that cliff. Insofar as this gradient
that we were talking about before in
light of the language you're talking
about in terms of this habit mode,
right, and exploration mode with respect
to collective governance or collective
systems used for simulating this
adaptive process as a collective,
that collective process of governance
can at times be in that exploration
mode, potentially discovering some new
form. So if you look at the inception of
the nation of the United States,
there's a lot of synthesis happening, a
lot of different ideas from a lineage
extending thousands of years into
history drawing from all of that to try
to synthesize a particular novel
framework. It was very conscious, hyper
conscious, hyper synthetic, very
exploration. But it created something
that in its stability and efficacy
became so functionally stable that
more and more people were able to move
into habit mode with respect to that as
a foundation. And as that happens,
interestingly enough, it opens up little
exploratory niches for actors to go in
and say, are there micro gradients in
that system? Because of the fact that
all these people are in habit mode no
longer their attention is focused
outwards, it's no longer attending
inwards. And so they actually go in and
start siphoning energy perhaps in their
own explorer modes as perhaps parasitic
behavior from this governance loop. But
interestingly enough, that can function
as a way of testing the stability of
that loop to some extent. Like they are
forcing that fundamental functional
closure of governance that people have
stopped attending to on Moss generally.
They're forcing it to operate under
additional constraints, under additional
load. Even though that load, that's an
internal load that it might not have
necessarily been formally designed to
bear, but that parasitism, like a
parasite load on any animal, is forcing
that animal to operate over and above
what they would have to do otherwise
without that parasitic load. And so it's
actually building some slack into the
system, perhaps, such that when we
start, when things start getting shaky
and people turn their attention back,
Hinton that system, see the parasites
and potentially get rid of them,
there's still enough slack left in that
mechanism, hopefully to navigate the
cliff or to smooth the cliff. So that's
like, a possibility. I'm not sure how
coherent that was. If that made sense,
let me know. It maps to, I believe,
pretty almost exactly to Brett
Weinstein's story about peacock
tails of pyramids. His argument is
effectively, peacock tails and pyramids
are exactly what you're talking about.
It effectively the peacock tail is not
just a pure sort of sexual display,
but it's actually effectively a
parasitic reservoir that provides a
fail safe to the degree to which the
context no longer supports it. You can
lose a lot of fucking tail, get back a
huge amount of adaptive capacity without
losing any real heuristic total fitness,
and respond to what's happening. Same
thing with pyramids. Like, if you put a
lot of social excess,
would that be called surplus into
pyramids, as opposed to, say, for
example, more people? Your carrying
capacity is actually buffered so that if
there's actually a significant drought
where food production is not as high as
it was, you just stop building as many
pyramids and you don't actually have a
Castro collapse of the underlying deep
structure. Was that in his thesis or I
haven't heard him talk about that.
Surprisingly, I've heard him talk about
a number. He did have shared this
public, so I may have just outed him. I
apologize. Force some reason, I thought
it was. Like I was like, yeah, because
in the Hunter Gatherers Guide, that one
or maybe I haven't read it once,
I need to reflect back on it. It might
be there, but yeah,
precisely. Certainly not surprising to
be the Brett and the mind that Brett has
in the way that he thinks. I think you
and I tend to dovetail and converge to a
lot of similar frames of reference so
that's, yeah, I think precisely these
abilities to maintain higher carrying
capacities within any given system
fundamentally provide slack in that
system. And if we look at it just at the
object level through almost entirely
moral framework, then it can
lead us to believe that there's no
benefit here and to perhaps be a
little bit overly acerbic in our
language toward what's going on.
Interestingly enough, it might have been
selected for we might be selected
precisely in the same way that we have
some interesting side effects of
psychopathy that might have overall
adaptive side effects at small levels in
society. Some element of sort of
corruption and parasitism at a base
level within even healthy systems might
be optimal to the extent we can talk
about optimality in such a system,
knowing that might brace us against
becoming overly cynical. Right. Because
I think that at some level, the greatest
threat to our current capacity for
adaptation is an abundance of cynicism,
and an abundance and the innervating
quality of that cynicism with respect to
sapping us of the necessary will,
energy, and belief that we can actually
do anything that is worth doing.
Daniel, how much time do we have left?
25 minutes. But I'm happy to stay on
anytime you want to. Feel free to
continue this section and then we can go
into Q and. A. I have another piece that
I'd love to drop in right here. So let's
see. Yeah,
the psychological consequences of being
stuck and almost
like the psychosocial consequences,
like the feedback loop. So on the one
hand you have the interior psychology of
being in something like simulated
thinking where you can't get out of your
own habits of thought and you can't
escape into a higher level of insight.
You can't escape back into Explore mode,
but also the feedback loops of being
stuck in a collapsing complex society
where Explorer mode is in fact inhibited
because it doesn't have any place to get
energy or resource, for example, or
positive feedback, the energy resource
and all the different human needs
modalities. And so what happens when
you're in there? And what happens there
is you start getting things like you get
depressed, you get cynical, you get
nihilistic, you get anomia. Right?
Okay, so let me think. Okay, I'll do it.
Free things first. That notion of
parasitism as a reservoir of potential
is very interesting and I can think
about that immediately in two ways. Two
examples that pop up. One is that
the notion of like 80% and 85% of people
are in so called bullshit jobs, or at
least self reported, which I think is
very reasonable, particularly if you
sort of think about the cascade effects.
Meaning if you were to remove a whole
category of bullshit jobs, you would
realize there's a whole other set of
jobs that are actually bullshit jobs
produced entirely by the first category.
So if you start unwinding them, well,
on the one hand, that's terrible. It
means that people are wasting their
lives and their energy and just
spinning. On the other hand, oh, well,
that's really good because that actually
means that I've got sort of 80% of the
human population is sitting on the
sideline waiting to be deployed
generatively as soon as we can get our
head out of our ass. That's nice. Catch
both ways. I also recall during
the 2008 2010 financial crisis saying,
okay, well, how far down does this
system actually call? It need to fall
for a truly robust reset, ie. If the too
big to fail system had been allowed to
fail properly, which is what should have
happened, what would that have looked
like? It's like, well, we're probably
not going to drop below like a 1972
level of standard of living. That's a
pretty big fall from where we are right
now. And I recall the 1972 was
actually pretty nice and it wasn't a
terrible style of life. And the point
being that there's almost something like
the what do they call the like the F 350
Hypertruck. Well, it turns out that if,
if we have to actually give up our F 350
and just scale back down to an F 150,
that's actually not that bad. We'll
survive. That's not a catastrophe.
That's actually a pretty decent amount
of fat built into the system that we can
allow to cut back and not lose our shit.
The challenge, of course, is, can we do
that elegantly? So then I'll get to the
third piece. Everything what I'm about
to say, from my point of view, is
entirely hypothetical. I am making up
this story on the basis of some
heuristics, but the notion is something
like this kind of dynamic of modal
opponent processing and some kind of
system that catalyzes the movement back
and forth between them is very, very
old, like, deeply fundamental. It's too
important not to be woven in.
Obviously, the sympathetic, sympathetic
nervous system go way back so that basic
structure is super fundamental and shows
up all over the place. All right,
second, humans at the kind of the first
APOC, indigenous humans almost
certainly, therefore, would have used
that at the social level. We would not
have been able to achieve something like
a social cultural style of collective
intelligence that didn't also have this
kind of structure woven in deeply, but
it would have been woven in deeply using
embodied cognition, obviously not design
cognition, because we weren't at the
design cognition APOC. So what does that
mean? What does it look like? The
proposition is something like when the
external context when the conditions
that we're in are signaling a
need to move to a group explore mode
exiting paradigmatic obligate
paradigmatic mind or stuckness exiting
habit mode into a more liminal
form of collective intelligence.
Every distinct human at an embodied
level will sense that differentially.
And they will suddenly begin to signal
that differentially back into the
collective environment. I'll give that
concrete.
It's been raining less and less. We
don't have concepts of rainfall.
We don't have meteorology. Like, this is
a long fucking time ago. But we notice
in a very fundamental sense, our bodies
are a little bit more dehydrated or the
energy necessary to get water is a
little bit higher. We're noticing the
prey animals are reduced are not as
common. We're noticing that yield of
food is decreasing. Noticing at the
physical level, deep, deep stuff like
biological. And then there's different
types of humans. We have a different
typology. We have old women. We have
young women. We have young men. We have
children. We have older men. And
probably, I'm guessing, something on the
order of, like, seven to 40 cognitive
typologies that cover the different kind
of modes of reality that it's useful to
have strengths and weaknesses in it. So
the collective intelligence at the
indigenous level is constructive
typological differences. Each of those
typological differences will have
differentiate and sensitivity to the
subtle signals of is it time for us to
actually move to a new niche? Do we need
to leave the valley and go into the
mountains? Because the rain and fall is
telling us the flow time is about to
come. That kind of thing, right? And
that will show up in behavior. That's
the key thing like actual physical
behavior. Physical behavior will
produce a second order feedback loop as
I notice the older women behaving in a
different way. It signals me in an
embodied level to begin that adds
additional differential signal to my own
perception and that will change my
behavior. So when I'm noticing for
example that the young women are giving
attention and perhaps sexual access to a
different kind of behavior in men, very
clearly this will change the behavior in
young men but that also will cause to
tend to cascade throughout the larger
environment. The idea is there's
something like a very very complex set
of multi typological feedback loops
pulling in subtle information from the
context that will eventually catalyze a
pivot from tribal paradigmatics
locked in very functional and effective
adaptive habit mode into. Okay, let's
all sit around the fire hand off the
Conor from the chief to the shaman.
Let's talk about the oldest deepest
mythological stories. Hey elders, are
you aware of anything like very
different mode? Right. The premise I'm
making is that that's actually the case.
I'm going to argue that we have that
that a large part of what's actually
going on. Like characteristics like
depression and cynicism are like
frustration. You know how frustration
works, right? Frustration is when
there's a deeply felt sense that there
needs to be some change in the world
that is building up energy to make the
change but the path to the change can't
actually be produced and the energy
effectively feeds back on itself. And
that's the energy of frustration which
eventually will either build to a
release this way or it'll
cut itself ant certain stores and then
will lead to more like depression.
Right? So that's a proposed like to put
out there that we're in a moment a big
part of what's going on is that we're
all receiving the signal that we need to
shift into this collective consciousness
mode, this liminality mode, this group
explore mode. We don't know how and
we're largely stuck. And so we're trying
to figure out how to make that move at
very macro level. Like there's lots and
lots of adaptive stuff going on, not the
least of which is the brokenness of our
body mind, our bodies and our mind in
relationship to just reality. Ideology
overriding our signals, like and body
cognition is way out of whack. And a big
chunk, maybe even like 90% of the chunk
of the problem that we're actually
dealing with is the journey of simply
restoring ourselves to that basic
capacity. Once we get back to that basic
capacity unlocking the 80% of people who
are sitting in bullshit jobs back into a
coherent collective intelligence that's
operating in a group explorer mode has
enough capacity to actually navigate us
to the niche we want to get to. So
that's taking the problem.
Of governance and say, okay, we can take
a series of steps and think about how do
we maybe find a way to work our path?
How do we find the path to get us back
to the location where we regenerate our
ambient indigenous capacity to operate
in this mode from which we should unlock
a vastly larger capacity to think about
these bigger problems.
Yeah, I mean, there's a lot there. I
think I could go on quite
the response, I think, in terms of time,
though, I think, Daniel, you did want to
bring in some live chat questions as
well, or in terms of where do we want to
go here? Because I could respond to
that. There's a lot of really
interesting points there. Or we could
weave questions into that context,
that frame. Where do you want to go,
Matthew? With a direct response. Then
we'll have a rapid question and answer
that will take us just around the time
that we agreed upon and feel free to
depart as well. And then at the very
end, I'll just make some reflections and
connect it to active inference. So first
Matthew, then question, and then feel
free to stay or leave and there'll be a
little Act-Inf reflection.
Matthew Pirkowski: Cool. Yeah. And in light of that, I was also really
wanting to raise some of the active
inference semantics and context in
response to in response to Jordan's
points. One interesting frame that I
feel is interesting to observe that it
hasn't saturated the culture, perhaps
just given the memetics of when and
where is introduced, but sort of like
EO. Wilson and Edward Lumsden introduced
something called dual inheritance theory
20 to 30 years ago. I'm not sure if you
encountered that. They had this book
called Gene's, Mind and Culture and
there's a lot of resonance with respect
to the mechanisms. They did a lot of
work with respect to the manner in which
the kind of diversity of behavioral
sensitivities, psychological psycho,
memetic and cultural level sensitivities
and behavior patterns have these kind of
emergent feedback loops that
essentially end up creating an emergent
form radial parameterisation at the
cultural level and the cultural
dynamics. These changes you're talking
about at deeper levels of reality as
they bubble up through and restructure
the cultural manifestations and the
sensitivities and behavior tendencies of
this diversity of psychotypes. I guess
you were saying how that actually, as a
mechanism feeds back into and back down
through all those other different layers
of adaptive implication, selection
transformation and sort of like this
emergent cascade and then this
essentially radial parameterisation
which many people have struggled with in
the past under the offices of the
argument around downward causation.
That's a whole slightly different
conversation. But I do think active
inference is very interesting from the
perspective, at least from my
perspective. Some of the work I've been
doing recently showing that in many
ways, active coherence offers
a one function in the category, the
necessary category of transformational
mappings between perception and action
that do exist at this deeply fundamental
level. In terms of the sort of
establishment of any causal closures,
either of any non trivially, complex
process, any cycle that's capable of
observation and action based on
perception, in relation to perception.
And interestingly, I think that that
does, by its very nature, in the way
that it connects to itself, give rise to
this bimodal topology, like through a
particular kind of non orientability.
And so the reflexivity, when something
comes back to you, has a different
orientation. So you actually have an
understanding of the relationship
between past and present via the lens of
duration because of the need to proceed,
even then impose some transformation on
the environment. Through that. I think
we're just beginning to develop the
capacity to work with those tools
in a way that doesn't impose.
That's more like surfing these adaptive
waves. That allows us to observe the way
in which these transformations and
perceptions are mapping onto actions and
using that as a tool in a toolkit of
explicitly and consciously designing
network connections between these many
different perceivers and actors. And
their perceptual and action capacities
in a way that can I don't want
to say provably, but in a principled
manner give rise to emergent systems
that do have these properties built in
endogenously and perhaps these signaling
mechanisms. Built in endogenously in
ways that can resonate with what you're
talking about, which is the embodied
sense that we have, intuitively or
unconsciously that arises, but we don't
necessarily have the language or the
framework to explicitly talk about it.
So sort of that emergent welling up
of emotion or frustration or depression
or enemy as you said,
gets shunted into language and cultural
symbols and representations that don't
Bull close back on the sort of actuation
capacities that we need to actuate or
that we need to upregulate in this
particular moment. And I think active
inference and other frameworks like it
precisely because they take this
perspective, epistemic perspective that
says actually you don't get to directly
observe the world. All you can do and
the best you can do is take this humble
process of trying the best you can to
connect signals of perception to signals
of action in relationship to preferences
at a given time and the context in which
they exist and build from there ground
up. I think it's a leading candidate
in the modes of phenomenologically
shifting our perspective through
new ways of operating and seeing the
world through new paradigms, through new
toolkits. So that's why I think I've
been really interested in the active
inference space and see it as something
that's quite relevant to this entire
conversation and in particular to your
final remarks there.
All right, excellent,
awesome. Thanks both for the dialogue.
This is really great. So I
will try to bring in many of
the questions that were asked in the
very active and energetic live chat
we'll get pretty quick thoughts that
will conclude the primary section of the
stream and then if you want to stay or
leave. But I'll just add a few more
points because indeed the connection
with active inference is very salient.
Okay, so into the questions we go first
from Charles Bloss. Hello, what are the
primary patterns including values of
wise exploration?
One was the one that you just noticed
which is moving at the pace of
wise collaboration. Meaning in this case
I noticed that's a very complex
question. I'll have to take a lot of
time to think about it. Yeah,
questions raised, we raised the
questions. Here and explore it in the
coming time. But feel free to give a
short response while you can. For sure,
I Dean, it's just interesting, I think
there's a confidence there because one
of the things that was coming to mind as
I was taking the time to try to reflect
on that was patience.
Especially in light of all of the
tendencies that shift us away from the
capacity to take in sufficient
information relation to
cycle. On that there's
a tendency to always want to,
especially under pressure, under stress,
to always want to take perception and
immediately map to action. Like for
every cycle of perception, some sort of
symmetric action because it field like
you're at least doing something feels
better than doing nothing. But there
might be some minimal necessary amount
of reflection you might need to cycle a
number of times at a number of scales
with a diversity of opinions before the
capacity is built up in that collective
intelligence or collective coherent
structure, before any action that it
takes externally can do anything other
than make things worse. And I think that
that's a massive problem that we're
confronting right now, because most of
our tools are designed to map perception
to some sort of extrinsic action almost
instantaneously. And we haven't created
the infrastructure that allows us to
more deeply allow for complex emergent
perception and mediated in the context
of action at the sort of duration and
depth required to meet the moment.
Great, so then a follow up comment and
then a question. So Charles followed.
Speaking of time, flagging an inquiry in
regard to timekeeping and calendars and
their specific numerics effects on
humanity's psyche and cultures related
to this patience. And Conor and Cairos
next question from Nathan Curtis at
what point in time, from instantiation
does the established government lose its
ability to be self referential and able
to look in on itself to identify flaws?
I've had a general thought about this
question. What I would say of course is
that the answer is it depends the
particulars matter and I think it's
going to be something like three primary
characteristics. One is going to
actually have to do with what's called
the shape or the topology of the
underlying architecture. So and
architecture like say liberalism has a
decent number of designed failsafes
very specifically consciously aware of
this problem. And so it's more like a
dissipative structure. It has a higher
capacity to actually live longer given a
particular call it gradient, using the
earliest language we were using.
The second, it's funny, you can
basically identify three very
straightforward principles. One is the
amount of energy, the amount of
information or potential that was
enclosed in the initial design.
The second is the intelligence or
elegance of design in terms of its
actual ability to produce structure that
most effectively navigates that
dissipation into entropy. The third,
and this is I think, a piece that we're
running into a lot is something like a
characteristic of bandwidth distinct
from time. Meaning the proper measure is
not chronological time chronos,
but is something like relational
interactions or loops of perception
agency, something like that. And so if I
think of say, an UDR loop is a kind of a
clock,
that is the right clock.
Awesome. That maps directly onto kind
of what I was mentioning with respect to
the active inference idea of duration as
time, right? In the sense that that is
precisely that cyclic relation in terms
of perceiving the consequences of action
as perception. And then internally,
inside of whatever mechanism is
perceiving and acting at whatever scale
we're talking about, that transformation
is sort of this era of time that we
perceive as the linear structure, that
linear mapping. But the real time. In a
lot of ways, the systemic time is the
path link through this causal structure
that flows between the action of any
given entity and the capacity to
perceive feedback in terms of what
those actions caused and how that allows
in light of the contextualized relations
that give meaning to the action, in
light of the values that are ostensibly
pursued. And so back to the question in
terms of when is the system capable of
or when does it become no longer capable
of that kind of self reflection? Well,
I would say to the extent that cycle
time, that capacity, that closure for
being able to understand the causal
affect of one's own actions in a
contextualized meaning grounded frame
to the extent that that is intercepted
or broken right?
Or to the extent that it becomes no
longer concerned with its own or COVID
cystic is another way of putting it. So
those would be conditions to the extent
that it actually becomes so trapped
in its own existing frame or its own
assumptions of causality. So this would
be active inference lab.
You have something along the lines of
like an over.
The precision of its capacity to
represent the world becomes far too
precise with respect to the relationship
between a very narrow subset of
modalities and factors in the world
exteroception and actions in the world,
which is exactly what we were talking
about earlier when we were talking about
in Jordan's language, the
decontextualization or like hyper
contextualization. And then that
prevents you from being able to identify
a very large percentage of the causal
structure that might be relevant to
whatever is threatening the coherence of
your collective intelligence or your
actual physically embodied metabolic
systems or whatever. That may be.
Awesome. Nathan wrote if we want
those representatives to embody a
certain aspect of being in that
position, how do we best select those
people? What modalities can we use to
select the best AI recommendation
systems? Temperament and Character
Inventory Test.
Personally, I'm fascinated by the
possibilities of emergent identification
of reputation like networks that
take advantage of the information
that exists in local relationships.
We might notice that to the extent that
we have elections at larger and larger
scales, we lose that right. Like in your
local elections, in a democratic
election or a democratic electorate, if
you're voting for sort
of like a county chair or a governor
or whatnot, you're much more likely to
have relationships or at least some
sort. Of socially contextualized
understanding of who that person is and
what the words that are coming out of
their mouth actually mean in
relationship to your embodied life.
But the further you get away from that,
the more you're dealing with
abstractions and so the more energy has
to be put into making those abstractions
feel real to you. And then you enter the
world of television news and political
news Cycles very myopically focused,
hyper precise, a lot of energy and time
put into those particular issues that
get the most attention as opposed to
those issues that tend to actually have
a more embodied affect on an
individual. So how do you actually take
advantage of surface that emergent
pattern of contextualized wisdom not
just within democratic elections but at
a much deeper level than we've ever
considered before? Because I think one
requirement of meeting the level of
complexity of the problems before us is
representing a much greater degree of
information. Without that information,
that information being at many scales of
our net emergent organism being the
nation state, let's say for now without
that information flow through the
system, overwhelming the system. I think
liquid democracy perspectives as a
general category are quite interesting
in terms of looking at them as sort of
like graph finding or path finding
algorithms of expertise that are
mediated by local expertise or local
relationships, local trust networks.
The trick with those is, I think,
executing those in a way that is capture
resistant. That doesn't necessarily make
that doesn't turn the entire game of
life into a game of politics. Such that
we are all campaigning all the time to
be perceived as the greatest expert in
whatever domain without actually
producing the action that would
naturally give rise to those
perceptions. It's a big problem. It's
like aping the behavior
that would lead to someone perceiving
you as successful. It's like the
instagram model or instagram personality
problem. It's like if you rent the jet
plane and put on the facade and you wear
the skin suit and have the persona it's
increasingly difficult for a large
percentage of people to divorce that
from the real signal itself. So I think
within liquid democracy patterns of sort
of emergent stewardship or
identification of people who might be
able to solve problems with greater
competence, that emerges as a problem.
And then there's also the problem of
response time. So it's like, to some
extent, the reason why we have central
executives or the reason why we have
individual representatives and place
authority in the hands of single
individuals is because there are
particular kinds of events that require
response that is at the scale of smaller
time windows than is typically capable
with processes that include large
numbers of people. So that's another
attention in terms of needing to solve
that without falling back into sort of
the central executive idea. But those
are just sort of the cluster of thoughts
that come to my mind when that question
arises. The first thing that
come up for me is that I would
profoundly caution that principle of
asymmetry that I'm
reasonably confident that the right way
to do this is to almost perfectly invert
our current way of doing things in our
habits and intuitions meaning a
radical regeneration of actual real
relationality and orientation of
sovereignty ie. Choice making authority
and power to the lower level more
intimate locations is profoundly the
right way of doing things. And so that
most people for the most of the time,
most of their choices are actually being
governed by high context dynamics.
And then on top of that substrate you
then can actually relatively easily
build a construct that allows kind of a
distributed Cincinnati where when it is
in fact very important to identify
individuals of extremely unique capacity
to deal with very specific problems that
agent available within even a vaguely
large local environment. You can press
them into it. But the point is that
they're so deeply connected 80% of the
time into and Attial lived context with
all the different strong bond, high
feedback loop, high context, high
subtlety that the culture into
the instagram model thing doesn't really
have. It's obvious that that's a really
bad idea. If you have people who are
living almost entirely in virtual lives
where there's really nothing real in
their lives, they don't actually have
real friends, they don't have real
territory, they don't have real
relationships with, even like their.
Parents or their siblings, then it's
very difficult for them to notice that
the instagram influencer thing is
terrible because they don't really have
something other than that that is
qualitatively distinct. But if they're
actually living a truly healthy life
with all kinds of good positive things
happening then you can pop into this
other role, notice that you really don't
want to live there, do your job and get
the hell back into a nurturing
environment. I should mention, by the
way, it's not clear to me that we can
actually get from here to there outside
of catastrophe. The navigation of that
particular path, at the very least is a
serious, serious, serious job, clearly
well beyond the capacities of anything
that we have right now. So it would be
kind of a trophic cascade of a series of
upgraded capacities that get us to the
point where we have that capacity and
that's reluctant. I think we've talked
a little bit about this or exchanged a
little bit about this on Twitter in
terms of one of those constraints. And
when you're talking I just kind of
wanted to get your take on this,
one of those issues with respect to
potentially walking that adaptive
valley, right, or trying to balance upon
that adaptive bridge line between our
current local maximum and perhaps some
sort of foothold on a larger
fitness landscape. Or higher point on
that fitness landscape is this idea
of national capacity in relation to the
geopolitical structure of the rest of
the world because we're operating not
brain evolution.
If we delegate responsibility, this
transformation that brings agency
outside of that central locus of
coherence that is now, this behemoth the
leviathan of the state with its primary
focus, let's say, or at least it's
Ostensible reason for being. As the
maintenance of the integrity and the
boundaries of the entity called the
United States or whatever the nation
might be at that scale.
As soon as that sort of starts to
falter, it's also perceived by other
agents on the landscape as opportunity.
And then, interestingly enough, is it
possible to maintain that transformative
traversal in light of whatever pressures
are added on top of our already great
list of pressures by other geopolitical
actors. And I suspect that's at least
one possible reason why you think that a
transformation like this will have to be
forced out of sort of terrific cascade
collapse or cascading collapses.
I'd be interested to hear your take on
that. Yeah, that's great. Just popped in
my head with this notion of pyramids.
So by hypothesis, let's say that the
American empire is one giant peacock
tail and so we're going to lose it. But
the good news is we can, we can afford
it. In fact, we're better off without
it. And so, yes, I think you're right.
And it's funny, it's almost like
expanding to fill a niche where we found
ourselves in this odd circumstance of
being first one of two superpowers and
then being an actual Global hegemon for
the very first time in human history.
And we expanded to fill that niche,
meaning we sort of depleted all of our
excess capacity until we unconsciously
and arbitrarily sort of deployed the
Global hegemon game all the way out to
the edge, right? And then we're sort of
pushing at the absolute limits of our
control capacity, by the way, in the
context of all these other things we've
been talking about, like local entropy
and parasitism, et cetera, and all the
niches that open up in that interior.
And I would simply propose that we're
already past that point. So one might
argue that any kind of change in
behavior comes with the cost of having
to give up the benefit of being a Global
hedge fund. And maybe you don't want to
do that. That's kind of a Tainter pivot
point. If you're familiar with that
point in the Marco,
I think that dies in cats, that we're
right now in the process of a forced
catscade down from that position into
some new multipolarity. And that can
be and I suspect we've probably gotten
the order of like three to five, maybe
seven more years for that to kind of
land all the way down. Very clearly
that that's where we are. But I would
say we're past the top of that point.
So it's a downhill roll from there. And
much like this notion of bullshit jobs
or the demoralization cynicism of being
stuck, we might find ourselves
demoralized by being unrooted from being
Global hedge fund. But we might also
recognize that that was actually never a
thing that ever that we really, really
aspired to be and could have been or
should have been. More importantly,
could have been. It was doomed in from
the very beginning. And that we're right
now being forcibly liberated from a
highly dysfunctional exploration, which
then, if you sort of shrink the scope
back down to a much smaller scope may
actually produce. A large enough,
large depth of time and control
capacity to afford us, called the
Generation and Generation and a Half to
reestablish a more generative governance
infrastructure. So that's an interesting
possibility at least. It's a nice story.
Wow, we're going to live a path
associated with that. At least it's not
that path. Something interesting.
Okay. To ask a few more questions, just
feel free to make sure. I have to be
very careful with timing because my wife
can be coming back with my four year old
and I have an immediate responsibility.
So we can we can go. But be mindful. I
may literally hit the red button to be
gone. Sounds good. Please depart as
family demands. So just I'll read a few
more questions and then again, I'll just
stay after to give a few reflections.
So what is a good example of a major
expanded decontextualization that we
live in that exists in the culture now?
Expanded? I didn't understand that. A
major expanded decontextualization,
maybe a broad scale. Okay. It might
be like a synthesis of the two ways that
we were talking about this and maybe in
terms of expanded decontextualization in
the sense of the
tendency to see the world maladaptively
through a lens that has grown so
large that we can see nothing else.
Perhaps the COVID policy COVID
policy is a great example of exactly
that. We built a medical and
health care what is it called, public
health infrastructure pulling forward
decontextualizing. A very large number
of aspects of embodied, embedded humans
and effective. What that did is that put
a series of knobs in the cybernetic
control structure. That when a real
problem came up that has extreme
systemic complexity. The way we ended up
dealing with it is we started pulling
these knobs as opposed to address the
underlying systemic complexity. We were
like, okay, lockdown. Why lockdown?
Well, lockdown may be an optimal
strategy if you think that you can shut
down the spreading of a virus and are
completely ignoring all the other
systemic consequences of lockdown. For
example, it was kind of like. You agent
over with the army. You have philosophy.
Except that the control board we had was
extremely low resolution and even
contraindicated by our own past advice
in many ways. But it was at hand and so
we pulled the levers, even though there
were plenty of us who were saying,
perhaps treating this as a giant light
switch is not wise makeup
and to. Comma from orbit isn't always
the best play. Yeah. And I would also
just extend that point into the fact
that beginning to reflect on that as a
society is also showing us that there
are a number of other
decontextualization or sort of like
frame lock issues that we have that have
built quite a lot of inertia around
them, especially around the domain of
what we call science, or what is now
parodied as science or scientism,
which is like the more serious
conversation that's been going on since
the advent of essentially early
postmodern philosophy. And in the van
sort of phenomenology like usurl and
Husserl's questioning of sort of
the paradigmatic and nature of science
as a way of seeing the world
that can displace all other ways of
seeing the world if we're not careful.
And the tendency of that to
because it has provided such again,
this is sort of this question of
exploration finding capacity and
then that capacity becoming so powerful
that it puts people into habitual mode
and that habitual mode becomes a
fallback if other levels of social or
psychological or even mythopoetic
coherence break down. So to the extent
that people lose other frames for
perceiving reality, perhaps for
interpreting their phenomenological
meaning, which is what the mythopoetic
frame has provided for so long, to the
extent that breaks down, sometimes for
good reason. I mean, again, there was a
lot of corruption in the church and in
religion and there was a lot of, I would
say, decay in the sort of interpretive
frames presented to upcoming
generations. I mean, I was one of those
people raised Catholic, initially left
the church, became essentially
antithesis for quite some period of time
before beginning to realize only through
evolutionary education and looking at
sort of the game theoretic lens in terms
of deep history, that there was
something there, there was a there
there, and that it wasn't necessarily
something we could jettison. But many
people have I think many people were in
that same position. And being in that
position have jettison in that frame,
falling back upon the purely scientific
frame, but not themselves doing science
being associated with the process.
Therefore falling into a dogma and being
willing to trust the high priests,
therefore creating an incentive for high
priests who are mouthing the words and
playing the game of politics as opposed
to really committed to the continued
process of discovery and transformation
and representation that we know of
science and getting ourselves into that
whole situation. And we're still a very
live conversation. We're still trying to
figure this out. And what is the
relationship between science? Can you
have a scientific exploration of
mythopoetic constructs? I think that's a
really fascinating possible field that
also active coherence would have a lot
to say in terms of the emergent
structure of collective behavior.
That's sort of the same kind of
questions, like really digging into and
beginning to examine the kind of
questions you were talking about earlier
with respect to what it means for
different people to have different
traits, tendencies, the perception,
personality traits, what that ontology
looks like you're saying maybe seven to
40 psychotypes or something like that.
What the dynamics of that as an
emergence system actually look like in
terms of their feedback and
parameterization on the underlying
structure and evolution of our society
and how mythopolitic structures and
scientific perspectives change those
perceptions and interaction with one
another and dynamic feedback mechanisms
with one another, or dynamics feedback
correlation with one another. I mean,
these are all questions for the next 50
years, right? I mean, very important
ones, I would say. Yeah, so I'd like for
this. We're listening. I like the fact
that you were actually, in describing a
decontextualized, can't remember
the structure, but describing the
structure, you also were articulating
where a lot of the failure conditions
emerge and how we find ourselves,
like this systemic shift. But you don't
notice that you're actually moving from
science into politics or moving from
science into theology into politics.
And because you don't even notice it's,
a thing that could happen is not a risk
that you're even contemplating in your
behavior. So you're finding yourself on
that trajectory. Maybe the mother of all
actually metaphor being where we are,
like, nearing the end of something,
the short answer to the question is kind
of everything. So everywhere you look is
a hypertrophy example of extended
decontextualization. So the problem is
actually being aware of what the
opposite might look like. But maybe the
mother of all is education, the
education system. I would say that
the current education system
decontextualizes humans, developing
humans so radically as to deprive them
of probably something between 70 and 90%
of developmental needs, which produces
probably a net yield of probably a 99%
reduction in total human capacity.
And many of the things that Matthew was
just bringing up, like the embodied
facility, not just not just the
cognitive scientific awareness. Of the
particular psychotypes and the
relationships but actually building
actual facility in navigating that
properly how you individual navigate the
world and how you can be in right
relationship with distinct other kinds
of humans in collaborative spaces.
Like, that's actually really hard. And
it's not the kind of thing that's easy
to learn when you're 50, right? It's the
proper thing to be learning between the
ages of like four and twelve and then
deployed effectively in particular kinds
of contexts between say twelve and 20.
Sorry, I'm doing the same thing. I'm
pointing out the things we don't even
notice that we have lost by virtue of
becoming hyper, hyper focused on a very
particular set of optimization
characteristics. And also education,
as I think a very big example of the
basic problem. I think that form of
education, to the extent that we can do
that, we can also begin to see, in light
of what you're saying with respect to
it's, almost everything at this point,
a key element of that almost everything
is the economic domain in which this
plays out. You could consider that sort
of like a hypertrophic exploitation
of supernormal stimuli,
right? What is a supernormal stimuli?
These stimuli that we have that are
essentially we've discovered as part of
this reflective process of discovery in
the domain of science. We've discovered
particular ways of tapping into evolved
perception action loops that are
unbounded in their sensitivity.
It's very hard to identify upper bound
for how the extent to which you
can advertise self undermining food
products or ways of spending your time
if in the moment those produce some sort
of extremely positive or extremely some
high salience positive affect experience
like eating sugar or getting that
dopamine release from the anticipation
of acknowledgement of one's perspective
online or these types of economic
threads that we have created are
specifically the profit maximization
thread. I think this is often put on the
shoulders of the word capitalism as a
pointer to some sort of hand wavy, like
there's something going on here and it's
capitalism. But I think at a deeper
level what we're pointing to here is the
fact that because of this very
long lineage of frames
that we have chosen and in many ways
like adapted to live within as a
function of past adaptive challenges we
now live inside this maximal
representation of those ideas
in a way that is no longer sustainable.
So like profit maximization as a myopic
focus leading to identifying those
narrow set of dimensions that are most
in line with that narrow metric over the
sort of corporate function and then
actually successfully tapping into
evolved aspects of human psychology
perception that are unbounded. It was
a search function and eventually it was
going to come to rest on like probing
the human experience in mind until it
found those parts that literally would
not you got to go. I got to go guys.
Sorry. Indeed. Jordan, great talk.
Thank you.
Yeah, that economic threat
is another threat to pull on. But that
was a great conversation in. This in the
active over time, I just want to run
through a few hits that I wrote down
from this great convo and just plant
some seeds for how maybe we can continue
35.2 or in the future. All right, so in
the very beginning, there was a
discussion of something like a meta
theory among the three of coon
with respect to science, hayek with
respect to business, and Tainter with
respect to politics. And we can
even see that meta theory as the
prototypical perception, cognition,
action or ecoevo divo loop. So you
spoke to the transformational mapping
between perception and action, which is
basically what cognition is. We just say
it's everything between that map between
perception and action and hence active
inference as a prototypical framework
for not solving but framing some of
these contexts. Then there's a
structured way of mapping those
exteroception onto available actions and
then identifying I mean, interestingly
enough, one of the most essential
aspects of the framework is that
capacity to switch between the
development or, like, reduction of
variational free energy in the moment.
Understanding whether my representation
of Parsing reality and action and what
I'm doing is actually in line with the
causal structure of my local environment
versus this explore exploit, future
oriented frame of reference in light of
when is it? Time to actually search out
some disruption or some entropy so that
that entropy injection into my locally
ossified frame can open me up again to
navigating that adaptive landscape and
introducing new maps between perception
and action that can facilitate my
continued adaptation. Awesome. So I
wanted to actually go to the free energy
with we had the earliest epoch of human
collaboration, which Jordan
characterized as sort of an unconscious.
And that is a lot like type one thinking
in the type one, type two system. And
it's a lot like variational free energy.
It's just this real time unfolding Bull
goes downhill modality type two
thinking, second stage civilization, as
per Jordan. And expected free energy is
where we actually have the double edged
sword of the rollout and anticipation.
And we've seen simulations in Ant IMF
where a tiny proportion of hypothesized
negative outcomes, even if they're
totally avoidable drive, rumination and
anxiety and high variance estimates.
And then the question is,
is there a third epoch, is there a third
mode that uses attention to modulate
the balance or the reliance between the
variational and the expected free
energy? And to what extent is that
attentional modulation implicit
tacit onboard, not automatable?
And to what extent could that kind of
wisdom be reflected in our externalized
niche? And that connects to the question
of automation and transparency around
our information architectures,
Communications and our infrastructure.
And I thought at first a sort of
infrastructural incompleteness or
instability theorem. Like, even if you
get all of layer one automated, then of
course, layer two has not been
automated. So there's always the hyper
prior and also that Min
two opponent processing thinking with
ten segregated architecture,
compression and tension. Could we have
systems where instead of just trying to,
oh, we want this object hanging here,
we'll just put a pillar underneath it,
and then we'll put a pillar underneath
that. Like, are we going to compress all
the way down or could we have a harmonic
mode that involved compression and
tension and that's how it stayed flying?
Then just go ahead. And then I have two
last points. I'd go either way. But
yeah, there's a lot of resonance here
with some of the things I'm working on
literally right now in terms of
attention to attempting to work
with active inference. Like I was saying
earlier, as that cognitive mapping,
that mapping, you can look at it also as
a category theoretic mapping within a
category a set of morphisms right
between this sort of space of perception
and the space of action. And you can
then also in that sense, integrate that
into a larger hypothesis around
the topology of emergence and then
develop that as a toolkit. Which is
interesting because inactive inference
through the lens of active inference,
in theory, everything can active
inference lab and then it leads to this
sort of recursive hierarchical
structure. But following thinkers
such as like Robert Ronen in terms of
his and like Vashevsky in relational
biology and bringing in theories of a
temporal causal structure that
basically can contextualize the temporal
unfolding of entailments, you can
actually use those understandings to
take active inference as a tool and
weave it into larger fabrics like you're
talking about. And those fabric
connections, they are related to active
inference, but they're not necessarily
active inference itself. Although you
could then take a meta step outside of
that and say we can apply the principles
to the entire system. But there's this
role of understanding novel closures,
of observing of reflexivity. And that
reflexivity, I think is really like the
approach I described as the approach I'm
taking to introduce a different kind of
reflexivity and a kind that I believe is
consonant with multiscale arbitrarily
complex emergence into the world of
active inference. But experimenting with
how to stitch active inference together
into itself I think is a very the entire
field is new and exploratory, but even
amongst that, it's that the sort of
periphery in the edge of exploration.
Indeed. And just these last two points,
belief Jorge was mentioned and
active inference helps us with the
composability legibility and simulation
evolution analytics on different
systems, physical cyber, physical
cognitive unknown, et cetera. So if
we're doing brikoulage on the edges now
we have the glue or the sticky tape or
whatever it is. And then last point was
on the peacocks and pyramids. It's not
so simple as just an adaptive buffer,
even throwing pletropy. So the
consequences on different phenotypes
aside because it becomes integrated
as the kind of thing I am. And so,
yes, it's like the eraser is the
capacity of the pencil, but we don't rub
our erasers all the way down. We're not
always on our last life in the video
game. And a symbol
that on one hand the energy could have
been diverted to some other purpose.
That symbol can actually become an
introduction at even the mythopoetic
level and therefore actually
lose its capacity to be an adaptive
buffer at one level and become a
pivotal player at another level.
I think that is also related to that
evidence scram problem, particularly
with respect to the abstraction of that
buffer as well. Right. So if you
abstract the buffer as well, the buffer
is, in theory, a signal of underlying
quality of behavior to accumulate and
accrete resources over and above
the requisite level of short term
consumption or metabolic need. Right.
That's the evolutionary instinct we have
for sort of appreciating someone who
has, quote unquote, gathered wealth, at
least by means that were constructive or
generative. But then to the extent that
that becomes associated with identity
and then you look at the signals as that
wealth manifests in a particular
culture, as the proxy measurement for
the underlying phenomenon, then you can
start to get into the manipulation of
those signals. If someone understands
and observes others behaving as if the
signals were the process of production
of that capacity for wealth, the
capacity for production of generating
wealth or useful. Byproducts then you
can see again this emergent parasitism
element dropping in there because people
will try to middleman that process and
say, if I can get you to treat me as if
I am that person, maybe I can get access
to whatever associated privileges come
alongside that. Yeah, 100%.
That's that identity association and
all of the games that it opens up are
essentially central. What your gain to
what we're talking about? What we were
talking about? Awesome. And a closing
thought. The discussion made me think of
a July 4 Fireworks for information.
What does it look like when the weaponry
is turned into livingry and when there
can be a symbolic ritual around the
utilization of that dual
function technology within
the boundaries across those levels?
Yeah, we're in a beautiful time for that
right now. I think so much of the
emerging technology, the generative
technologies out there, especially under
the offices of AI or ML,
the capacity to use that generative
toolkit and its ability to allow
people to a much broader swath of people
to produce potentially resonant artistic
and cultural artifacts that are pointers
to something they find unique or
interesting or insightful that might
then spread if it aligns with a given
moment or need. And that's particularly
fascinating to me as a catalyst
for increasing our capacity to think
collectively transcending just the
verbal domain and bringing in other
sensory modalities aligned with the word
I. Dean that's the funny thing about
these LLMs, right? Like, they're large
language models. And language can act as
that fabric, as that language,
as the neural network itself, as the
computational network between these
other sensory apparatus, and the ability
to produce artifacts that bring people
into forms of alignment or
phenomenological resonance that just
would not have otherwise existed. Now,
there are potential downsides to this as
well, just like anything. But I'm very
excited about that because I look at,
you know, the all of the art that I've
seen, this new generative artwork,
it is, like, you know, very much
informational, fireworks. Right? People
are able to take five ideas that they
heard today. You could go, you know,
based on this podcast, you could
basically say, like, take any subsection
of that, produce a series of generative
artworks, and then associate that
lineage or series of generative art
with this as a network, a visual network
that could be a dynamic placeholder that
could attract attention automatically
from the potential network that
resonates with that artwork. Right. And
tap into the latent space of this
conversation that none of us hold
explicitly in our heads, but we're all
pointing to it based on our words and
our conversations and the kind of things
we're trying to talk about here. Like,
there is a latent space representation
possible. So, yeah, I think we're in
fascinating times for that and using
that as a tool constructively and
wisely. I'm looking forward to seeing
that part of this unfold. Thank you,
Matthew. Thank you to Jordan. Till next
time. Thanks, Al. Always a pleasure.